[Music]
hey out there you guys
so how do you feel about cannibalism
so this is my tomes of terror show where
i talk about
books review horror books and thrillers
too sometimes
now this book if you guys have been
watching some of my past videos
um and i did a video that was my
uh 2021 tbr and i showed you like the
contents of my big huge book pile
and um you know just to kind of give you
a heads up about what i'm going to be
reviewing in the upcoming year
now you may note that this book was
actually not on there
what ended up happening with this was
that every time i went on amazon to
order something
amazon was like man you need to read
this book it kept like putting in my
recommendations
and then it turned out to that a lot of
book review channels that i read had
picked this as
one of their favorite books of 2020 and
you know
just couldn't stop recommending it and
also i have to admit i was very drawn in
by a lot of them saying
it was one of the most [ __ ] up things
they had ever read which to me
i'm like ah i'm intrigued and also i
will say
that any book that if you go on
goodreads
and it has a five-star review and then
underneath it the only text of the
review says
jesus christ i'm on board with that i
want to see what the hell the [ __ ] is
all about
so i finally caved into amazon and i
said okay fine
send me a copy of the book and let's see
what this is all about
so this is probably infamous at this
point
tender is the flesh by agustina
now evidently this author is argentinian
and i believe this is her second novel
she won a [ __ ] ton of awards for it
i think this originally came out at
argentina in 2017
but the english translation which was
done by sarah moses
um actually came out last year like in
early 2020. i think most of the reviews
i saw were from like february or
something
so it must have come out around then you
know how when i was reviewing
kin by caleb patrick burke and i was
just kind of like you know all the
content warnings okay um
that for this book too but times 100
you know what i mean if you are bothered
by
let's see what what all's in here it's
like i said this is a book that's
entirely about cannibalism
industrialized cannibalism there you
know there is so there's cannibalism
there's rape
there's horrible animal cruelty there's
just violence there's just all kind of
it's just a shocking
really really graphic really really
detailed
book so if any of that is going to
bother you
and i will say too that i'm still a meat
eater but
if you're a vegetarian and you read this
this might validate your life choices
and i have seen some people that are
meat-eaters that have read this and are
like
i don't know if i i'm gonna eat meat for
a few days at least just because
this book is like really disturbing and
uh
yeah so let's kind of get into it and
like i said before
i will probably spoil some plot points i
don't
know and like i said this is kind of
like one of my one of my things where
it's like i never really
know if i'm gonna spoil the ending until
i actually get to that point
when i'm talking about it because this
has a really a gut punch
of an ending and i don't know if i want
to spoil it i will
we'll find out when i get there but i'm
just saying that this is there's going
to be plot points that i'm going to
spoil so if you don't want to know
anything about this book and you just
want to go into it blind obviously
then go read the book and then come back
because i'm going to have like some kind
of discussion about it
about its themes and stuff and you know
there might be some plot things that are
spoiled for you that you might not want
to be
even if i don't necessarily tell you
what happens at the end which i may when
i get there but we'll see
so i think that the closest
equivalence to this book i guess it's
a fable it's a dystopia it reminded me
it's very orwellian it reminded me you
know
1984 animal farm a little bit like the
road
because this [ __ ] is [ __ ] grim this
book is
grim there is no humor in it i mean it's
just
unrelenting horror and tragedy
and sadness so like i said it's it's
just a horrific horrific read
that said it's like i still found it
really compelling though even though
you're reading it and you're just like
oh my god it just makes me want to kill
myself
but not but in an entertaining way i
know it's like a really weird thing to
say but if you've read it you might know
what i'm talking about
also i've seen it compared to or it has
like similar themes to
uh the jungle by upton sinclair now some
people
and i can't really speak to this but
some people have said
there's a book that came out i don't
remember when it came out but it was
called
meat and it was by somebody named joseph
de lacy
and a few people have come forward and
said that this book is
i don't know like a ripoff of that or a
similar kind of theme i don't know
because i haven't read that i'm just
saying that that's what some people have
said
but this is very much in an orwellian
type of vein where it posits
and and like i said it's kind of like a
like a fable in the sense that
the [ __ ] that happens is realistic as in
there's nothing supernatural or anything
but it's exaggerated
a little bit to make a point because the
thing about it is that like some of the
stuff that happens in here
it might not happen like that in real
life like if a situation arose
as a rose as arises in this book
but it's all in the service of
getting its message across and making
the point that it's trying to make
because i saw like a few people that
criticized it
on goodreads it seemed like a lot of
their criticism was well
this wouldn't happen like if if a
situation like this arose in real life
this is not how [ __ ] would go down and
i'm kind of like well
maybe not but that's not really the
point that she's trying to make with
this book is that that'd be like telling
george orwell man farm animals don't
talk what the [ __ ]
you know what i mean it's a fable is
what it is and it's satirical
to an extent i don't know if i'd call it
satirical just because
it's not funny like not even in a black
humor
sort of way like i said it's just really
really grim it's just unrelenting
grimness i don't want to say it's
wallowing in like the worst that
humanity
does but it's just making a point about
well i'll kind of get into like what the
themes are so here's the setup
for this book this takes place in either
a near future a dystopian near future or
possibly an alternate future it doesn't
really matter
and i'm guessing that this is argentina
because there's
just a few place names and stuff that
are mentioned it's not really again the
um
location is not really that important
because this is more like a fable
now what has happened is that sometime
in the very recent history as in so
recent that
the guy you know the protagonist of the
book
can still remember what things were like
before or at least it was
either in his generation or his father's
generation you know before things
all went to hell so it wasn't that long
ago
so there was an epidemic like a virus
that broke out i sent i kind of pictured
it sort of like super rabies or
something like that but like i said the
details of it are not important
that kind of spread to all the animals
and made the animal meat no longer
safe for consumption by humans
and it came to pass too that everyone
got so flipped out
about the animals spreading the virus to
the humans
that animals were essentially wiped out
and even
every idea of them has been wiped out
it's even illegal
nowadays to have like pictures of
animals or because there's one point
where like the guy who
is the main protagonist um he had like a
son that had a
little cot and it had i think like a
little bear or a little ducky or
something like that on it
and he's not allowed to have that
because they just want all
mention of animals and you know all idea
of animals to be eradicated
so there's that whole thing so what
ended up happening
is that since people were still
so hung up on eating meat
the government came in and did a thing
called and it was like the transition i
don't really know how long it took and
was like i said again the details
don't really matter it's not like a
world building type of book it's just
more like a fable or like a dark fairy
tale type of story that's said in the
real world but
you know with details like i said it's
the greater themes that matter not
really the little details
so the government came in there was this
period called the transition where
they're basically like well
you guys still want meat and we can't
eat animals anymore all the animals have
been
wiped out so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start farming humans
for consumption so that is essentially
what they start doing
so you're already getting a sense of
this sort of stratified society
where you have the people at the top um
and not even just rich people either
it's kind of middle class and up or
whatever
and they're operating within the system
where
humans are bred and
slaughtered just the way animals are
nowadays there's a whole system to it
so the protagonist of this book is named
marcos
tahoe and he is a manager at a
processing plant and it is a human meat
processing plant and it's set up pretty
much
just like an animal processing plant
would be nowadays
the first half this book is in two parts
so in the first half of the book
you kind of get um a sense of it's not
so much like a day in the life but it's
kind of like
you're following marcos around on his
job because he's a manager for this
processing plant which is one of the
best regarded ones like they have the
best
meat or whatever even though they don't
call it that but i'll get into that in a
minute
so you get to see him going around to
these different situ because his whole
job
is to go around to various places
you know and pick up people's orders and
figure out what kind of
humans they want like for whatever their
purposes are
it's a really good way to introduce this
world because this is this guy's job
he has to go around to all these
different places whether it's butcher
shops or game preserves or something
like that anywhere that would order meat
and he has to go around and so you get
to see different aspects of the society
and how this
legalized and industrialized cannibalism
has
affected society as a whole and you get
to see like all different aspects of
that
through his job and through his rounds
now
while you're doing that where he's kind
of just going through his work week or
whatever
you also get a little bit of a back
story
as to what's going on in his personal
life
now his personal life not doing so great
uh his wife cecilia has
left him possibly temporarily it's just
that they had a
son they were really really trying very
hard to conceive and like they had i
think they had had
ivf and all that and um it took him a
really long time to have a baby because
they really wanted to have one
and then they finally had one and they
were really happy and then their baby
died it was like a crib death so you
know there was no one to blame it wasn't
an accident it wasn't anything like that
so he's really really having a hard time
processing the fact that he wanted this
son
so badly and now he's gone and
his wife is also really having a hard
time with it and
she has gone to stay with her mother
because she just can't stand being in
the house she can't stand being around
him because it's
you know it reminds her and whatnot so
he's got all that going on
and also his dad who he is very close to
and his dad actually
worked in a slaughterhouse back in the
old days before the
transition when everyone could still eat
animals
so marcos has been in this line of work
you know he's like the second generation
i believe and maybe his grandfather was
even in it too but now he just made the
transition to
slaughtering humans instead of
slaughtering animals
so his dad who he was very close to has
dementia
and he's in a home and he's really not
doing very well he's having episodes
and so forth and so marcos is kind of
conflicted because he hates his job
and he sees that it's barbaric
but he needs the money to keep his dad
you know at this place so it's almost
kind of like well he's trying to keep
his head down and
you know try to do what he has to do
just to earn money just to get by
so you have all this going on and like i
said you know the first half of the book
is basically
him going through the motions going
through his life you get a little bit of
backstory about him you get
but i think like the main part of it is
the
descriptions of his day-to-day life and
how
how this industrialized cannibalism has
changed society and in a sense
it has taken away people's
empathy it's really interesting because
i could see some people saying that this
book is essentially
a polemic or is like against factory
farming
which it definitely is because there's a
very long and very
very detailed and very revolting and
disgusting
sequence where he is giving two
potential employees a tour of the plant
so you go through the whole entire
slaughtering process and it is very very
vividly described
and you can say oh that's like stomach
churning that's gross and everything but
it's the same thing
that that we do to animals if you eat
meat
so just the fact of them making it a
human
it just shows i guess it shows how much
distance we have away from it because
when it's done to animals instead of
humans so when it's done to humans it
becomes really shocking and really
disgusting so that's definitely one of
the points that she's trying to make
is that not necessarily oh we should all
be vegetarians because i don't think
that's what she's saying
i think that she's saying she's trying
to point out kind of i guess the
hypocrisy
of being disgusted by this stuff when
it's done to a human
when we're not necessarily as disgusted
by it when it's done to
an animal and and potentially like not
even
because obviously if you saw something
like that that done to a pet which
there's kind of a scene like that later
on in here too
so like i said trigger warning for
animal cruelty because
even i had a hard time with that one
it's like some of the cutting up meat
like human meat and stuff i was just
kind of like yeah it's pretty gross but
you know but then when it got to that
one scene i was kind of like
oh i had like this really horrible
feeling in the pit of my stomach
but yeah she was just kind of pointing
out like the hypocrisy of
you know we have pets or we have empathy
for other humans but
now that society has become so
stratified
what they've done is that they've taken
essentially
it's not even an underclass because
that's like a whole different thing
which i'll mention in a minute
but they're farming they're just
breeding
people and their whole purpose is
they're going to go
to the slaughterhouse and they're going
to be slaughtered for meat and other
people are going to eat them
they don't even call them humans though
they call them head
as their head of cattle like you know we
got this many head today like came in on
the truck
and it's all kind of in the service of
dehuman further dehumanizing
these humans just so other people can
feel better about
eating human meat and making themselves
feel like they're not eating
other humans you know what i'm saying so
the humans that are bred
for meat are obviously
uh treated in horrific ways
they are their vocal cords are cut out
so that when they are slaughtered they
don't scream
uh which is another thing that makes all
the people that work in the factory like
they don't have to listen
you know to you know or face the
consequences of what they're doing
they're killing another human being
they have brands all over them um
the pregnant women uh their limbs are
removed when they get pregnant so that
they're not
so that they can't harm the baby because
you know that's a very important
commodity and
obviously baby meat is also kind of a
big delicacy too because you knew
they were going there so they don't want
anything that's going to
mess up their investment which is human
meat and i should it should be noted too
that every part
and he kind of goes into this when he's
giving the tour to the employees
that every part of the human is used
they use their skin to make leather you
know because i'm
in this world there's really no animals
anymore
um you know there's still birds and [ __ ]
but it's like you know
big land animals there's no more of
those so they um you know they use their
skin for leather they use their urine
for various things they use their blood
for things although i don't remember if
they ever said specifically but
yeah so there's a part in it where
somebody says well what do you use the
blood for he's like well we use that for
other purposes but i don't think they
ever like specify what it is
and uh there's also a trade in some of
these
humans that are bred for slaughter
are also experimented on because as i
said we no longer have animals to
experiment on so that
now they just experiment on humans so
one of the really interesting
things that this book does and i think
one of the main i don't even know if i'd
call this a subtext
because i think one character even says
something
like this and you know it's even kind of
brought up in the first paragraph of the
book
is that the way we frame things the
language that we use to describe things
makes it easier for us to deal with
atrocities
that we do you know what i mean because
i think the whole point of this book
here's the really interesting thing and
as i said i don't know because i haven't
read it in the original spanish
obviously i just read the translation
but from what i can determine the
translation of it's actually very good
the style of the book
is very direct it's very brutal it's
very
matter of fact and she wrote it in that
way
because she wanted to illustrate how
the language that we use can normalize
something
even something as horrific as people
being raised as essentially cattle
for the slaughter so one of the subtext
of the book as i said one of the themes
of the book
is that it's very easy to
normalize horrors
when you're not referring to them as
what they really are
so in that context in this
world you're not allowed to use the word
cannibalism you're not allowed to call
it
human meat it's called special meat
you're not allowed to refer to these
people as humans at all you have to call
them head
or product or merchandise or something
like that you can't refer to them as
humans
because the you know the government the
corporates the pa
the corporations the powers that be
don't want you to see them as humans
they want you to see them as just like
breed animals
for your consumption so that's basically
another big point that she was making
and another interesting thing and i
didn't really realize this while i was
reading and i think i realized it like
the next day like after i finished
reading it
is that even though the the main bulk of
the book which as i said
it's told from his point of view but not
in the first person you know the
sentences are just very short very
direct it's not real
it's descriptive but not flowery the
only time that she uses
metaphorical language is when she's
talking about someone's words
or their voice or something like that
for example you have the beginning of
the book
which is basically just carcass
cut in half stunner slaughter line spray
wash
it's just kind of like that the whole
thing isn't like that roll staccato but
it's just this very brutalist very
straightforward way of talk of uh you
know
getting the ideas across but when she's
talking about
someone's words she uses metaphors
like uh his sister's words are like
boxes filled with blank paper
things like that so you know where
someone's words are black holes
or something that's the only time that
she ever uses
metaphor really because that's one of
the main themes of the book is that
language
forms thought and if you can be
convinced to feel
okay about something then things can get
super horrific
and it'll be okay because you're
justifying it by
your use of language and euphemism and i
think that's like a really big theme of
this book
now when we get to the second part
because as i said the first is almost
kind of like
you know a tour of this world as it is
even it doesn't come across like that it
just comes across like this guy
who's having kind of this shitty time
you get the sense that it
just like in a lot of orwell's books
like a lot of his protagonists where
they're unhappy with this world and
they're kind of
you know trying to maneuver their way
through it but
you feel like at some point they might
break free and just be like you know
[ __ ] all this or whatever
that's not exactly what happens in this
though just saying
but yeah so so it's just this tour of of
what the world is like
kind of seen through this guy's eyes who
has become very
desensitized very dehumanized in this
world but he's not
happy about it particularly because of
all his all of his personal faults
now right about the halfway point of the
book as i said this is in two parts
receives or a little bit before the
halfway point i guess he receives
a gift in the form of a
head a woman who well
they can't call it that who has been
bred for meat
and she is what they call an fgp
first generation pure now a lot of the
meat that they make just like they do
with
animals is genetically modified and
they're given hormones to grow faster
and all that kind of stuff
however if you get one that was actually
naturally birthed
that's a very very valuable commodity
because essentially it's like organic
i guess it'd be like organic meat
because it's just like this was a woman
that was raised like a normal person
and found with regular things and wasn't
given all of these hormones and whatnot
so he receives her as a gift from a
client
and as i said she's first generation
pure so she's really really valuable
but he reacts the way he's like what the
hell am i supposed to do with this
it's like well now do i have to
slaughter her i'll have to take
somewhere
take her to somewhere else like the
butcher shop to slaughter her i could
sell her i could do this that the other
thing
he doesn't really think of her like a
person because
he's been conditioned to think of meat
the same way we would think of like you
know
cattle that we're going to slaughter or
whatever so he basically just
he's like man it just seemed like too
much trouble
and so he just kind of ties her up in
the barn and like you know throws her
some
water and feed every now and then and
and all that kind of stuff
but as the second part of the book goes
on you get the sense
that he's starting to see her
almost like a person now obviously she
can't talk uh she's completely
uneducated she has
she has no idea what's going on um she's
as i said she's been bred to be
slaughtered so she's
you know i imagine she has some kind of
rudimentary human intelligence but she
hasn't been
taught anything or anything like that so
you know kind of all she knows is
fear and just reacting to things so he
keeps her in the barn for a while but
since his wife has been gone and he's
been so upset
you know about his son dying and then
his father ends up dying
and he's kind of as i said you kind of
get a sense that
he misses the world the way it was
there's there's kind of a running thread
where he keeps going
back to this zoo which obviously is
closed now because all the animals are
dead
but he used to go there with his dad
when he was a kid and he used to
remember
like all the beautiful birds and the
aviary and the monkeys and everything
and you get the sense that he wants to
go back to that world
so you do get a sense that he does some
have some humanity remaining
and his relationship with this
woman who he actually ends up giving a
name
jasmine because that's kind of what her
smell reminds him of
so you think that he's kind of going
toward that that
he's you know his humanity is still in
there
you know because there's a there's a
scene there's scenes with her
there's a horrifying scene where well
it's two scenes actually the first scene
where he finds a bunch of puppies
in the zoo because not all the animals
are dead but it's just you know they're
they've been trying to you know
eradicate them because
of the virus and they're afraid that the
virus will spread to humans and blah
blah blah so
but there's still you know wild dogs
running around every now and then but
not really and everyone's like terrified
of them
so there's a scene with some puppies and
then like some really horrible [ __ ]
happens to the puppies later on so
yeah that's that was really upsetting
you get the sense that he still
has a humanity in there that he hasn't
been that it hasn't all been crushed out
of him
by the way that the world is
but it's interesting because
the way this ends i don't think i'm
going to spoil the ending out right but
i'm just going to say
it's it doesn't go maybe the way you
think it's going to go it goes
in a more maybe like a 1984 a brave new
world type of direction
and at first when i read the end i was
just like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man like i
felt like somebody punched me in the
stomach
and because i didn't expect it but the
more i thought about
the book and a lot of the imagery in it
that's
where it was heading the whole entire
time i guess i just didn't really see it
because there are a bunch of he has like
a couple of really vivid dreams
a couple of times and the imagery that's
portrayed in that dream
like now that i'm thinking about it i
was like oh that's what that was saying
that he wasn't actually even though he
still had these little tendrils of
humanity in the way that he treated
jasmine because he and he actually ends
up
getting her pregnant now i should say
that this is really really illegal this
is one of the
ironic things about this world that is
created in this book
is that humans are bred for meat
however slavery is still considered
barbaric
and you are not allowed to have sex
with the head you know the
the the humans that are bred for
slaughter it's it's really really taboo
it's really really illegal
if they catch you doing it they will
send you
and the head to the slaughterhouse so
you will get slaughtered also um however
he does actually end up having sex with
uh with her
and getting her pregnant it's almost
kind of like the second part of the book
like i said it almost kind of leads you
down this primrose path it's like you
know oh everything's gonna be okay she's
gonna have a baby he's gonna
fight the system and you know you know i
have a baby with this
woman who's just considered like a like
cattle you know and he's just gonna like
run off and they're gonna be happy
somewhere and
like i said spoiler alert that does not
happen which i guess in a way is a more
realistic kind of ending
i should note too though that even
though it's technically
illegal to have sex with the
meet humans obviously just like in the
real world
uh if you're rich you can get it with
pretty much anything so
there are and actually he does go and
visit
a game preserve where
basically if you have a lot of money you
can go and hunt
humans and then if you kill one
then they will prepare it like it's a
big country club type situation
and they'll prepare it for you all nice
and fancy and you can sit there and eat
it you can have whatever
piece you want and all this other stuff
and then
when he's there the one guy that runs
the game preserve who seems like this
very like
european kind of uh aristocratic type of
dude
and he says well you know there are
other places you it's not this place but
there are some other kind of
underground places where you can
have sex with the with the meat humans
as much as you want and then you know to
even though for everyone else it's
illegal
i should mention too because i think i
forgot to mention this before there's
also
i know i said earlier that there's not a
lot of world building in this but now
that i'm thinking about it now that i'm
kind of
trying to go back over all the little
details that she kind of fills in about
this
i'm like oh maybe it is kind of like a
big world but you know i don't know i
guess it didn't occur to me because it
was
very organic the way it came out but so
you also have
a group of people called the scavengers
who were kind of like
you know the the lower classes or
untouchables if you want to call them
that
so these are basically just bands of
poor people who are starving
and they will go and get
if you okay so there's a curfew so if
you go out
after curfew then basically you are fair
game if you get eaten by the scavengers
then that's your own goddamn fault
because you were out after dark or
whatever
they also there's also a thing now where
you can't really have funerals anymore
you just have to
you know if your loved one dies and you
don't want them to get eaten
then you have to go immediately to the
crematorium and they put the
body in a clear casket and put it in the
crematorium so you can see that they got
burned and then you have to sign the
thing that says it got burned you know
they
nobody got it or whatever so there are
scavengers
and they um basically some of the bigger
plants including the one that marcos
works at
will kind of throw them like if there's
like some shitty meat
that you know got damaged in transit or
it was dead when it got there
or something like that they'll throw it
out to the scavengers
other meat that gets thrown out to the
scavengers is this isn't gone
a huge amount into but there's a little
bit about this
where there's this religious sect that
has sprung up i think they're called the
church of the immolation
and they have a weird thing where they
think that your life is not valuable
unless it has gone to feed another
person that needs it
so the members of this sect periodically
will come to they all kind of um someone
agrees to be a sacrifice
and so they will all come to the plant
and um
they will give themselves up as a
sacrifice
and um they you know because they think
it's this big thing that they're doing
for the world
and they do this they have this kind of
agreement with the plants to do that
so they can keep their tax-exempt status
i think is what it was so that's come as
kind of a weird like judeo-christian
kind of eat of my body flesh kind of
thing so it's like people taking it
literally
but those people that sacrifice
themselves the religious people they are
also
fed to the scavengers because it's seen
as inferior
meat because it wasn't you know it
wasn't farmed it wasn't raised
properly you know it didn't have all of
the things that they like
their meat to go into because they have
a reputation to uphold so as i said
this book is essentially the theme of it
is
humanity as monstrous as humanity can be
we can almost justify anything if we
couch it
in the correct terms i kind of feel like
that
is where she was going with that because
as i said people are
just perfectly willing to turn a blind
eye
that fellow humans are being
butchered and served up as meat as long
as we don't
call it that as long as we call it other
things they can't like i said they can't
even call it human meat they call it
special meat
even all the pieces that they sell in
the butcher shop because there's also
this woman named spinel that he visits
at a butcher shop
and you know they they'll cut off the
hands and sell the cans but it's called
like upper extremity they can't even
call it like hey it's a human hand
because people don't want to know that
that's what they're eating
so that's kind of the overarching theme
of the book is that this monstrousness
people are okay with it because you know
they're getting something they want
they're getting meat they're having a
quote-unquote sort of normal life which
is all they want
and as long as they don't have to think
about it then
they're fine with it so it's almost kind
of like complacency
and another thing another theme too is
how easy it is to undermine
people's empathy for others um as i said
especially when you're couching it in
this particular language
because you know obviously the people
that they're slaughtering for me
they don't see them as people they just
see them the way we would see a pig or a
cow
so that's another thing too it's very
much class stratification
all that kind of stuff and like i said
this is very orwellian
and you know the grim tone of it kind of
reminded me of the road a little bit too
uh i've seen some people compare it to
soylent green which it is kind of like
that as well
i will say this is i can see why
so many people said this is one of the
most [ __ ] up things they ever read
because
and i think the thing that makes it
[ __ ] up i mean yes it is very
graphic and yes the detail is very i
mean it is
just intimate details of going i mean
picture going through
a slaughterhouse and just like imagining
because that's exactly what happened so
she just like very matter-of-factly like
lays out this is what we do in this room
and this is what we did and she's like
just describing it it's not
over the top it's not it's just very
very direct just very
laid it all out there and that's what
it's like and she so she's trying to
just get you to look at it you know
without any
flowery language without any euphemistic
language
that's just what it's like and
kind of asking the question are we okay
with that you know what i'm saying but
the thing about it i think
that's what makes it more [ __ ] up the
way that it's written
it's just kind of and i've seen some
people mention this too when they were
talking about reading the book
they said as i went through the book
you know it as horrific as a lot of the
[ __ ] that happens and it is it almost
becomes
normalized and i think that's exactly
what she was trying to do she was trying
to show
how easy it is for
even something as horrifying as
industrialized cannibalism and like some
of the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that happens in
this book
how easy it is to just get numb to it by
the way you know while you're going
through the book so i think she
was like a masterful way of doing that
like
using the language to kind of get her
point across
on top of the actual story and the
actual things that happened in the story
which was also getting her point across
so it was like really
it was like a really good meeting of you
know the way the language was used
in service of the theme of the book i
think that was like really good because
it did get to a point where
horrific [ __ ] was happening and you just
kind of like yeah you were just kind of
you got desensitized after a while and i
think that was kind of the point that
she was making
so and like i said i think the ending of
this
was [ __ ] great it's a it's a gut
punch of an ending like i said you're
gonna
i i felt like yeah i felt like i'd been
like socked in the jaw
at the end because i was like what you
know because i guess i was expecting it
like i said i was expecting it to go
hey here's because so many of our books
are kind of like just one guy fighting
the system and it was like yeah go guy
um and you've kind of thought that this
was going to go in that direction but it
really doesn't go in that direction
and then it shocks you but then when you
think about it and you think about all
the stuff that happened
back you know throughout the book and
you think about all the imagery and all
the dreams that he had
and you know and then it makes complete
sense but when you're reading it it just
seems to like just
[ __ ] blindside you and come out of
nowhere but the more you think about it
you're like oh well there's really no
other way that that could have
ended because it you know given the
context of the world that he lives in
what the [ __ ] was he actually gonna do i
mean it was just was like
unrealistic like thinking that he could
just you know take on the whole system
or whatever which
like i said he really does not so as i
said if you're not
into real real graphic [ __ ] real world
grim
[ __ ] this is not a fun read not by any
stretch of the imagination there is no
humor there is no nothing is just
unrelenting
bleakness and grimness but that said
it's also really really compelling and
the more you think about it and you will
think about it
the more its themes really kind of
resonate because yes it's exaggerated
yes
it's unbelievable in the sense that you
know if all the animals
died we couldn't eat animals anymore i
don't you know especially like nowadays
i just feel like everyone just go to
meet substitutes because that's become
like
you know mainstream to an extent or
everyone's used to the idea of it
and i think it would take a lot to get
people to actually get on board
with the idea of eating humans the way
we would eat
people but that's the thing you never
know and
the way that it happened i could i don't
know it's it's not
believable like i said but under certain
circumstances i could totally see it
happening
but i think like i said the
believability of it isn't
that that's not the issue that's not the
point that she's trying to make it's a
fable
it's not supposed to be completely
realistic it's just
it's trying to show you an alternate
reality
to cast light on our actual reality you
know what i'm saying
in that sense it kind of reminded me of
uh that
i think it was a spanish movie called
the platform which was on netflix
it kind of reminded me of that in the
sense that you know obviously the
the plot of it the framework of it is
not entirely
believable it's like you know where is
this building where are these people you
know who's
up there like who built this
infrastructure with the platform coming
down with all the food and stuff like
that
that's not what's important the whole
point is that you were using fiction
to to make a point about our real life
you know what i mean so that's kind of
what this
is so if you like really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and you think this is not gonna bother
you and like i said content warning
cannibalism animal cruelty
rape all kinds of terrible terrible
things happened in this book probably
probably more terrible things happened
in this book than any other book i've
ever read
probably a lot of books that i've read
put together but it is
brilliant and i can see how a lot of
people how it got all these uh prizes
and
how it got it's already been translated
into nine languages definitely if you
really like [ __ ] up [ __ ] and you
really like
dystopian kind of [ __ ] and you think you
can stomach it because
if if you think yeah this is not for
weak stomached
people at all um you know it's it's
gross and it's nasty
and uh it'll put you off your food for a
little while but yeah
tender is the flesh by augustina
bastarika fun fact
i think in the in the the native spanish
i think it was actually called exquisite
corpse
which um you know is also a good title
and then that had like a little bit of a
reference within the story of you know a
couple of the
his i think it's his niece and nephew
was like a game they were playing
and i think that's a real thing isn't it
like exquisite corpse it's like some
kind of poem or a game or something like
that
so uh but yeah they changed it to that
because i guess they figured
nobody would know what exquisite corpse
was in this game no poppy zbrite had a
book called that didn't she yeah i don't
know
but yeah so definitely if you like
[ __ ] up literature then
uh give it a read and let me know what
you thought about it in the comments
below
and i'll be back to do another book
review next week
and i'll see you in the next one bye